Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get to the Friday mailbag where you
can write to me and sometimes it'll appear
on the show.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com,
ideally with a substantive commentary, but
sometimes there is very little substance and
that's okay.
I want to start today with an email from a
right winger, I think, who thinks they're
on to me.
They think they know my trick.
Take a look at this message.
Andrew wrote to me and said, It's a nice trick.
Good afternoon, sir.
I notice that you only discuss the dumbest
or the dumb Republicans on your show.
It's a nice trick.
It's the same trick, Tucker and Sean HANNITY
and Don Lemon and many others use.
You will find no shortage of idiots on both
sides of the aisle.
And what you do is shine a light on just those
people.
Do you ever plan on having a conversation
with anyone that you can't tip the outcome
in your favor?
If your arguments are so good, you should
be able to talk to anyone, not just the pillow
guy and Jesse Lee Peterson or whatever his
name is.
I read the comments your audience writes,
and I must say that the most ignorant that
they the most ignorant and misinformed people
in America.
And what's scary is that these people think
they are the smart ones.
I don't even do this for a living.
And I can pick apart every single one of your
arguments, or at least show where you are
being a hypocrite.
I honestly used to really like you.
I now I like to hear solid arguments from
both sides.
But now I realize you are just a fraud.
I might as well call you HANNITY Junior.
It's the same playbook, bro.
You know, we've.
So, first of all, they never tell you who
the smart conservatives are.
Tell me exactly who they are.
Because they go.
Well, Ben SHAPIRO.
I interviewed Ben SHAPIRO on the show.
It didn't go great for him.
It wasn't like terribly humiliating, but it
didn't make a lot of sense.
And then he's refused all subsequent invitations.
I've had Michael Knowles on the show.
Some of these right wingers go, Knowles is
the smart one.
To the extent that Jordan Peterson is a right
winger, people say, well, but Peterson's been
on and he has an open invitation.
We tried to get him back on recently.
We had Andrew Sullivan on.
He's a right winger and I find him to be intelligent
and I know those are the right smart right
wingers or they're they're not really right
wingers or whatever.
We we interview all sorts of people.
All sorts of people.
This is a very boring criticism.
Let's go next to Earl now.
I'm going to be totally honest with you.
I don't know if this email from Earl is satire.
Earl wrote in about raising the minimum wage
and said, I am so disappointed to see encouragement
from your people to raise the minimum wage
to $15 an hour.
This could destroy capitalism as we know it,
forcing millions of businesses and CEOs out
of work because people are too lazy to work
and too stupid to budget.
I am not an economist like Thomas Sowell,
but I can do simple math.
So let's start.
725 an hour is 290 a week.
That's $15,080 for the year.
Average health insurance is only 150 a week.
That's $600 a month.
Average apartment rent for a one bedroom is
only 275 a week.
That's 1100 a month.
Average food costs for one person is only
$51 a week.
Average transportation 65 a week.
Utility bills 35 a week.
So to survive, we don't need a $15 per hour
minimum wage.
All the person has to do is work two full
time jobs and drive Uber in their spare time.
I'm sure that's what Milton Friedman or Thomas
Sowell would do.
If this is satire, it's very well done.
If it's not, then it's kind of weird.
But I think because I can't tell, I'll do
it as a presenter without comment.
John wrote in.
John says Hi David.
Huge fan of the show was excited to find for
you to find another right winger to interview
this week with John T Smithy.
I think it was I think it was John Teague
as a tool for your viewers to understand when
confronted with the new IRS hiring goals,
that 87,000 number often thrown around is
misleading.
This is really important because right wingers
are loving this talking point of why does
Joe Biden need 87,000 more IRS agents?
Well, John explains.
First of all, it's based on a proposal from
May 2021 and not actually relevant to the
current plan.
Number two, the IRS expects 55,000 retirees
in the next ten years.
These new agents would replace those folks.
Three The new hiring quota would be over ten
years rather than immediately.
You know, that does change the big picture
of that IRS hiring, doesn't it?
John writes, I'm a CPA who has had this discussion
multiple times a week with clients.
And I've got to tell you, they look really
dumb when I turn this around on them.
Well, John, I always appreciate more information
and John does seem to know exactly what he's
talking about.
I'll keep that in mind when they pull the
IRS talking points.
Glorious Taco wrote in saying, Shouldn't Abbott
and DeSantis be arrested for those immigrant
busses?
David In the past couple of months, Abbott
and DeSantis have been sending busloads of
illegal immigrants to various Northeast Democratic
run cities, claiming that illegal immigration
needs to be dealt with now.
Shouldn't these two be arrested for knowingly
transporting illegal aliens across state lines?
A federal crime?
And what money is being used to fund these
trips?
If public funds, should that be another federal
crime?
Yeah, we talked about this on Monday.
NPR has a really good article about the possible
illegality of the de Santos migrant Martha's
Vineyard stunt.
I don't want to rehash everything I said.
You can check out that clip.
But G.T., you are spot on in identifying there
are a bunch of possible crimes there.
A bunch of possible crimes.
Anthony wrote in about Michael Cohen, Trump's
former lawyer, and says, Hey, David, I'm not
sure if you addressed this before, but I've
been listening to the Michael Cohen podcast,
and I noticed a couple of times that he referenced
you as the guy that goes to Trump rallies
and talks to Trump supporters.
I don't think he has the right guy unless
you've been out there in which I'm sorry I
even addressed this.
I thought maybe he was thinking of Jordan
KLEPPER or some other mockery type journalist.
Yeah.
So Michael.
Michael Cohen's a great guy.
We're in touch and he's a supporter of the
show.
We're going to have him back on soon.
I like Michael Cohen.
He sometimes refers to me as a comedian, which
I'm glad to be called, although I'm about
to show you a voice and an email that says
I'm not funny.
But to the extent that Michael Cohen finds
me funny, I'm glad for him to call me a comedian.
Michael Cohen is also said the guy that goes
to Trump rallies.
And when Michael Cohen interviewed legal analyst
Asha RANGAPPA, Aisha also said, I'm the guy
that goes to the Trump rallies.
So we've sent people to Trump rallies.
We will also sometimes look at clips from
Trump rallies.
I don't know where it all came from it.
Your guess is as good as mine, but I know
exactly what you're talking about.
Huma here is someone who doesn't like my humor
or says I'm not funny.
Like the show a lot, Dave, but find your humor
a bit lacking.
Not a complaint at all.
But the dim sum word with Boebert cracked
me up.
She's in my district as Peter's in Mesa County.
Trial date for Peters that was just set is
six months from now.
No lack of loons around here very much appreciate
your efforts, says Tom.
You know.
Does it make sense to say that my humor is
lacking when it's not a comedy show?
I don't know.
I mean, it's sort of like if you said I didn't
like what's a really like hard boiled TV show,
kind of dark.
I don't know.
There's this there's actually a really good
German time travel show called Dark.
And it is a dark show.
It would be weird to say now the humor is
lacking.
It's not a comedy series, so I just don't
know about this.
My humor is lacking.
It's not really meant to be a comedy show,
so I don't know.
Let me know what you think about what Tom
has to say.
Mike in New York City also wrote in, Mike
said, David, I always found it hilarious that
MAGA people think they're being clever by
saying, Let's go, Brandon, and that they think
this bothers anyone on the left at all.
I think Democrats should co-op.
You mean co-opt should co-opt the phrase.
Let's go, Brandon.
They should start chanting and in support
every time Biden does something good.
Yeah, that would be funny.
You know, a lot of times taking back the phrase
is kind of silly.
In this case, I think it would be funny for
the left to also start using Let's Go.
Brandon is a positive.
One of the cringe iest things is when these
right wingers you can you see them and you
can.
They think they're so smart and clever and
incisive when they go, let's go.
Brandon and some of them email me and they'll
say, David, can you tell Brandon to pay attention
to his teleprompter or whatever, you know,
that type of thing?
And they genuinely think they're being super
clever.
It's cringe.
The entire let's go Brandon thing is one of
the youngest out there.
And the funniest part of it is how clever
they think they are.
They will never change.
At least that doesn't seem like it anytime
soon.
Make sure you were signed up for our bonus
show.
Oh, my clippers.
An even plane.
That was weird.
It like came out of the wrong speaker anyway.
You know, Alex Jones doesn't like the bonus
show.
Just remember that to me, that's a great endorsement
of the bonus show.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com and get instant
access to that very same bonus show.
We've got one coming up today right after
the podcast.